SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone.
My name is [? Shin, ?]
and in this video,
I'm going to demonstrate
how to deploy
a HIPAA-aligned foundation GCP
infrastructure using Terraform.
And I'm going to
use the Terraform
Engine and the CI/CD pipelines
from the data protection
toolkit to facilitate and to
simplify the whole process.
What is Terraform Engine?
Terraform Engine is a framework
to jump start your organization
onto GCP.
It is an open source
Terraform module generator
that puts together
Terraform resources
into complete
deployments with values
that are specific to
your infrastructure.
Terraform Engine offers
different types of recipes.
And here, I'm demonstrating
the foundational recipe,
which is the most
common based IPs
that health care focused GCP
infrastructure should usually
set up.
So what is a foundation recipe?
Foundation recipe helps you
set up a structure like this.
It will help you set up
a DevOps project used
for remote Terraform state
management CI/CD resources
to test and deploy
your Terraform
configs automatically.
It will also set
up a Audit project
which is used to host two
audit log sinks, a short term
one-year BigQuery
log sink and also
a long-term seven-year
Cloud Storage log sink.
And in addition, the
foundation recipe
also set up a
monitoring project,
which is used to host the
Forseti infrastructure.
And Forseti is used to scan and
monitor your GCP organization
for potential security
policy violations.
So this is actually a
Terraform Engine config,
and now we'll use this
to generate the Terraform
configs using Terraform Engine.
And so here, you can see
I'm specifying the recipe
to be the foundation recipe from
the default templates offered
by Terraform Engine.
And in each of the data
block, I can specify
details for each component.
So for example,
for DevOps project,
I specified the project ID
to be dpt-demo-1-devops.
And similarly, for Audit,
I can specify the name
or the project ID for
the project itself.
And I can also
specify the set name
and also bucket name
for the audit log sinks.
And note that we also deliver
a setup default organization
policies which is based
on best practices,
and it's a good setup
organizing policies
that you can use to start
with in your organization.
And also, here we
have the CI/CD block.
This block will configure
the CI/CD components
which will set, for example,
which GitHub repo to monitor,
which branch to monitor
to detect changes, push
to that branch, and auto-deploy
the changes in that branch
to your GCP infrastructure.
And it also allows set
additional, for example,
project owners to a specific
group and things like those.
And also, note that there
is a disabled block,
and there's one attribute
set to true, which
is a bootstrap GCS backend.
So the meaning is
in the term config,
it generates that are used
to create DevOps project
and essential remote
state bucket configure
that specific deployments
to save the state locally
not remotely.
The reason is because that
deployment specifically
is creating that DevOps project
and the remote state bucket
used to store the remote state.
So if we haven't
created those resources,
how can we store
the state remotely?
So we have to do this
in a two-phased way.
First, we set this
to true, meaning
disable the remote's
backend, so the state
will be saved locally.
And then I'm going to
flip this to false.
I'm going to regenerate
the Terraform configs
with the changed
config here, and that
will give me the new config.
And that config will have the
state configure to remote.
Then I can roll
on terraform init
to back up the state to
the remote state bucket.
So a quick overview for what
I'm going to do in this demo.
So I'm going to use Terraform
Engine and this config
to generate the
Terraform configs
and save them to a
local Git repository.
And they will later be
checked into my private GitHub
repository, which will
be the source of truth
for the Terraform configs for my
testing or demo infrastructure.
Then I will manually
deploy the DevOps project
and the CI/CD resources.
So later deployments
or modifications
to our infrastructure can be
made through pull requests
and auto-deployed by post
submit cloudbuild jobs
once the PR is approved,
tested, and merged.
Then I will make a commit
to include all the configs,
send it as a PR for review,
let pre-submit test to run
and pass.
I will merge the PR and let
post submit cloudbuild job
to kick in and auto-deploy
the rest of the resources that
were not deployed manually.
Those will include the audit
project, audit resources,
monitoring project, and
the Forseti resources.
And a few things to
note, Terraform Engine
does not create
the organization.
We need to create an
empty organization first
and configure the billing
account properly, as well.
And the person who is going
to do the initial deployments
of the DevOps project
and CI/CD resources
should have the
necessary permission
to create project, use
the billing account,
set IAM permissions
at organization level,
and other ones if necessary.
So if we actually
go to a terminal,
and I'm going to run
the Terraform Engine
binary or command.
So Terraform Engine is
shipped as a go binary.
And so first, let me show
you this directory which
will be the target
directory that I
will use to save the
generated Terraform configs.
And it is a local
Git repository,
and it is configured to--
or connected to my private
GitHub repository here.
And this repository is
specifically, this one,
right now it's empty.
I'm going to send PRs
to include in my configs
to this remote repository.
So here, to run the
Terraform Engine command,
I run something like this.
So I specify the
config path, pointing
to the demo.yaml, which is
this file I just showed you.
And then I specified
the output path
to be the Gitrepos-demo,
which is this directory here,
and now it's empty.
So now, I run this command.
It's pretty straightforward.
So now, I come back here.
This directory's
no longer empty.
As you can see, three
directories are generated.
And if we open this directory
and see what has been created.
So let's see the
bootstrap directory first.
So if we look at
the main.tf, we can
see that this Terraform
config is actually
creating the DevOps project
using the project factory
model.
And it's also creating
a storage bucket,
and this bucket will be the
Terraform remote state bucket.
And it's also configuring
additional IAM settings.
So this will go first.
I'm going to deploy
this manually first.
And remember, I'm going to go
back to the Terraform Engine
config, flip this to false,
and regenerate the Terraform
config, so that will make a
change in this part actually.
And I'm going to
do a terraform init
to back up the state
for this deployment
to the remote state market,
as well, after the state
bucket has been created.
And after the bootstrap
directory is completed,
I'm going to move on
to the CI/CD directory.
And this directory configures
the CI/CD pipelines.
And this one has to be done
manually before the CI/CD
pipeline is actually created.
So this one actually
configures a bunch of APIs
and also IAM permissions to
enable the cloudbuild service
account to view and
to make modifications
to your GCP infrastructure.
And most importantly,
it configures
three cloudbuild
triggers, two pre-submit
triggers to watch for PRs,
Pull Requests, and the one
post-submit trigger to
watch for pushes, too,
to a specific branch.
And in this case, I'd
configure that branch
to be master branch.
And this config's
directory contains
the actual cloudbuild
config that
will be executed in
the cloudbuild job.
So once that is
completed, I'm going
to send a PR to include all the
configs in all three folders,
bootstrap, cicd, and org.
And remember that the org folder
was not deployed manually.
So that will be handled
by the CI/CD pipeline.
So let's take a look
at this org folder.
So the org folder contains
all the other resources
that does not need
to be done manually
and all the resources
that will be
handled by the CI/CD pipelines.
And in this case, as part
of the foundation recipe,
it will create
the audit project,
create audit resources,
create the monitoring project,
and create the monitoring
resources, which
is a Forseti infrastructure,
as well as the organization
policy, as well.
And so if we actually
open each of directory
and take a look, so
this project.dpt demo 1
audit/project, the
configs in this directory
correspond to the config that
creates the audit project
but not the other resources.
The other resources are actually
contained in this main.tf
under the audit folder.
As you can see here,
we are enabling
all possible audit logs
for all three types
and all supported services.
And we are creating
two audit log sink--
the BigQuery one and also
the Cloud Storage one.
And as you can see, for
example, the Cloud Storage one
is set to expire in seven years.
So that's the audit.
And let's take a look at the
monitoring component, as well.
So similarly, this
monitor/project, this main.tf
contains the Terraform
config to create
the monitoring project itself.
And then, if we go to
this monitor folder,
open the main.tf,
as you can see here,
we are creating the
network for Forseti.
We're creating another
router and a net
to enable Forseti to
communicate, because Forseti,
we always set it as
a private instance.
So we need that net
to enable Forseti
to communicate to the internet
to download certain packages
during startup.
And then, we use
this Forseti module
to set up the entire
Forseti infrastructure.
And this is actually
pretty complicated,
because Forseti has few
components, including
AVM, [INAUDIBLE]
Cloud Storage buckets,
a bunch of firewall rules,
and also a Cloud SQL database.
So this will be handled
by the CI/CD pipeline.
And lastly, let's take a look
at this organization policy
folder.
So this is the
organization policy
delivered by the Terraform
Engine templates by default.
We did not configure
them with any attributes.
And these are the four ones.
I know that, for example,
if you specify allowed share
to BCP host project to
only specific projects,
those information will be
propagated to this part.
And then once these
policies are enforced,
only those projects can be used
as share to BCP host projects.
So that's a quick overview
of the configs that
are generated by
the Terraform Engine
based on the Terraform
Engine config here.
So now, let's do the
actual deployment.
So first, so this is
the directory containing
the Terraform configs.
So let's do the bootstrap
deployment first.
So to do Terraform
deployments, we first
do terraform init,
which will pull down
the module resources and other
Terraform provider resources.
And this is now complete.
Then I do terraform apply.
So usually, you can
also do a terraform plan
to show the plan of
the resources it's
going to create or modify.
And in this case, because
terraform apply also
shows you the plan, so it's OK.
So I should take a
look at this plan,
making sure it is
doing the right thing.
And it looks good to me, so I
press Yes to let it continue.
So this deployment will create
the DevOps project and also
the central remote
Terraform state bucket.
As you can see that it's
creating the project, and all
of them are handled
by Terraform.
I do note that the state,
the Terraform state,
for this deployment
specifically is stored locally.
And we are going to modify
the Terraform Engine config
to change that disable
attribute to false
and regenerate the
Terraform configs.
And the new one will have the
state configured to be remote,
then we do terraform init
to back up the states.
So it's almost finished.
It's creating a bucket, the
bucket has been created.
And it's completed.
So now, I'm going
back to this config.
Change this to false, meaning
save the state remotely.
Then I rerun the Terraform
Engine command to regenerate
the Terraform configs.
And here, let's take a look
at what it has changed.
So the thing it changed
is actually this part.
It adds as an additional
block to configure the backend
to be GCS and using the
bucket that are just created.
So I'm going to do a
terraform init to transfer
the state from local to remote.
So it detects that the backend
of the state has changed.
And it asked me if I want to
transfer the state from local
to remote, and I answer Yes.
So this part is done.
So that means the bootstrap
deployment is completed.
So after this, and moving
on to the cicd folder,
or CI/CD deployment.
And the one thing that
I need to do first
is I need to manually
connect the GitHub
repo to the cloudbuild
triggers in the UI,
in the Cloud Console.
The reason is because I need
to grant cloudbuild permission
to access my
private GitHub repo,
and that part currently is not
supported by any automation.
So this dpt-demo-1-devops
project was just actually
created by the
previous deployment.
And here, I'm connecting
the repository,
and I'm selecting
the GitHub repo.
I choose the right
GitHub account,
and I choose to choose the
right repository and Connect
Repository.
It will ask me if I want to
create default push trigger.
I skip for now because I'm
going to create my own triggers.
So this part is completed.
So actually, since we are
on this Cloud Console,
let's take a look at the
state bucket we just created.
So this is a bucket
that was created
by the previous deployment,
and it's here already.
So now, if we go back to
this directory, and then we
go to the cicd folder,
and we do a deployment.
And similarly, terraform init,
and then terraform apply.
And I take a look at the plan
of the resources it's going
to create or modify for me.
They all looks fine, and
I type Yes to continue.
So after this
deployment is finished,
I expect to see three
cloudbuild triggers being
added in this page, and
they are not here yet.
So these are completed.
And if we go here,
and I refresh, and I
see three triggers are created.
And if we open one
of them, we can
see it's configured
to watch for my repo
at the master
branch, which is what
we have configured in the
Terraform Engine config here.
So at this point,
I'd configure or I
have deployed the bootstrap
part and also the CI/CD part.
And so the rest of the
configs in the org folder
will now be handled
by the CI/CD pipeline.
And actually, at this
moment, I can remove myself
as the organization
admin or [INAUDIBLE]
user from the
organization since I've
done all the manual
steps that I need to do,
and the rest should be handled.
And it can be handled,
by the CI/CD pipelines.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to make a commit to include
all the three folders.
And I'm going to send
a PR, a pull request,
trying to merge these
configs into the master
branch of that private
GitHub repository.
So just make sure that
I'm on the dev branch,
because I'm pushing
to the dev branch
and then making a PR from that
branch to the master branch.
And I include all
the configs that
are created by the Terraform
Engine and then make a commit.
Let's say auto-generated
by Terraform Engine.
And save and exit,
and then we push
this commit to the
remote dev branch.
And it will come to this part.
And then let's create
a pull request.
And as you can see,
it has all the configs
from the three directories.
Then we create a pull request.
So as you can see,
two pre-submit job
has started running.
And those are the two
pre-submit triggers
we have configured to watch for
PRs sending or trying to merge
changes to the master branch.
And so because I'm
using a personal repo,
so I cannot configure
branch protection rules
to, for example, block
the submission of this PR,
if some pre-submit
test has failed.
But in a enterprise or
organization repository,
such as Google Cloud
Platform, you can
and you should configure
the pre-submit tests
to block submission of your PR.
And also, I should ask for a
review from one of my teammates
for the demoing
purposes and just
skipping that part for now.
But in the actual
development cycle for prod
or for dev or
other environments,
you should ask for a
review from your teammate
and also making sure that
pre-submit tests passed.
So let's take a look at
what are wrong in those two
pre-submit tests.
So let's take a look
at this one first.
So this one is doing a
Terraform formatting check--
Terragrunt formatting to make
sure the code health is good.
And we're also doing
a terraform validate
to making sure that there's
no simple syntax errors
in your Terraform configs.
And let's take a look
at the other one.
That one is still running.
And this one is actually
printing out a speculative plan
similar to what we just did.
In the local machine, when
you do a terraform apply
or a terraform
plan, it demonstrate
or shows you the
potential changes that
will be made to
your infrastructure
when the change is applied.
So this is the
similar idea where
we are running a terraform plan
to show you the changes that
will be made to infrastructure.
And in this case,
we are deploying,
or we are creating the
resources for the audit project
and the monitoring project.
We are also configuring
the organization policies,
which are all the
configs in the org folder
that was not deployed
manually by me.
And they are now handled
by the CI/CD pipelines.
And the [? figures ?]
import, as you can see here,
on this deployment.
And this one specifically is
creating the audit project.
And this one, specifically,
is configuring
the audit logs for all
three different types
and also for all
supportive services.
And these are configuring
or adding the two log sinks.
And the rest are
mostly for Forseti,
because I think Forseti has
about 50 to 60 resources
to be created.
So in a development cycle,
you should take a look
in detail of what is
going to be changed
in your infrastructure,
especially where there
are deletions.
So for example, we
add an extra step
at the end to detect potential
deletions of resources
that will result
if you are checking
your own merged changes.
And in this case, because
you were creating everything
from scratch and no
[INAUDIBLE] found.
So that plan looks good to
me, and both tests passed.
And I assume I ask a code
review from one of my teammates.
Now, I can merge my change
to the master branch.
So once I merged the change,
another cloudbuild job
will kick in.
And as you can
see, this one here,
and this is the
post-submit deployment
job which will actually
do the terraform
apply for me to apply
the changes that
were just shown in
the speculative plan
in the pre-submit job.
And it's going to print out
the terraform merge just
for archiving purpose.
It's going to do terraform init.
It's also going to
show a plan, as well,
and eventually, it's going
to apply the plan to your GCP
infrastructure.
So by the end of
this deployment,
I expect to see the audit
project being created
and audit resources being
created and configured
in that project.
I expect to see the monitoring
project being created
and also the Forseti
infrastructure
to be setup in that project.
And I also expect to see the
organization policies being
configured according to
the ones that are delivered
by the Terraform Engine.
And this part will take
about 11 to 12 minutes,
because one of the major
pieces that will be created
is Cloud SQL database, part
of the Forseti infrastructure.
And that takes about five or
six minutes to be created.
So we are just going to
wait for that to finish.
And right now, we are still
at the planning phase.
Then after this is
finished, we will move on
to the apply phase.
And I think if you are
watching this video,
you can fast forward
for about 10 minutes,
and then we will have all the
resources provisioned on GCP.
So this deployment
has just finished.
So this deployment help us
create the audit project, audit
resources, monitoring
project, monitoring resources,
and organization policies.
So if we go to the Cloud Console
and take a look at the projects
it has created for us.
So it creates the audit
project, the monitoring project.
So if we go to the audit
project and go to the storage,
you can see that the seven-year
long-term storage log sink.
And if we go to the
BigQuery, you'll
see that BigQuery
log sink, as well.
And now, if we go to
the monitor project,
and this project is used
to host the entire Forseti
infrastructure.
And as you can see, it creates
the Forseti storage buckets.
It also creates the
Forseti server VM.
And it's up and running,
it's a private instance.
And before you go to
the Cloud SQL database,
you can see it has also created
the Forseti server database.
So that's for the monitoring.
And if we actually
go to a terminal
and try to print the log
sinks for this organization,
and you can see that there are
two log sinks being configured.
And each points to the right
destination we just created.
So by now, we've finished the
deployment of the foundation
recipe provided by Terraform
Engine with the help
of CI/CD pipelines.
So future deployments
or future modifications
to infrastructure, if
you are, for example,
adding a new project or if
you are adding a new storage
bucket, they should be sent
as a PR to this repository.
And the same thing, you will
go through a code review,
make sure the pre-submit tests
pass, the speculative plan
looks good.
And then once you submit
the PR, the change
will auto-deploy by the
cloudbuild deployment job.
And one thing I want to
mention in addition, as well,
is for Forseti, because
right now, Forseti
also needs to consume
a set of policies
in order to know
what type of rules
you want to enforce on
your infrastructure.
So DPT also provides another
tool called Policy Generator.
And that's a tool that
is also configurable.
And it's based on templates.
And it can provide you a set of
best practices Forseti policies
that you can upload and let
Forseti consume right away.
So I think that's all the
components that are included
in the foundation recipe.
And that concludes
the demo today.
And I hope you enjoy the
video, and thank you.